she mixed with the rich and famous
[Music]
presidents and royalty i've met her
numerous times over the years especially
since i lived in palm beach i wish her
well but also a prolific pedophile we
need to get to the bottom of everybody
who was involved with that starting with
gilan maxwell
now gillane maxwell is in court and on
trial
after decades of explosive abuse
allegations she's now facing the fight
of her life
so who is guillain maxwell what charges
is she facing and will she take the
stand
[Music]
gillane maxwell is 59 years old the
ninth and some say favorite child of the
disgraced media mogul robert maxwell
she worked for her father as director of
oxford united football club which he
owned and at his newspaper the european
robert maxwell even named his yacht the
lady galen after her
the very yacht from which he disappeared
in 1992 his body was later found
floating in the sea and i love him and i
listen
and to be angry he's pointless he's dead
after her father's death gelaine maxwell
moved to new york using her connections
to continue living among the elite
we were all part of the sort of british
expat world in new york and she was this
sort of glamorous mysterious exotic
person she was always
name-dropping that she'd been with
incredibly important powerful people
whether it was henry kissinger bill
clinton
we've never known the truth about the
relationship between geoffrey epstein
and gelane maxwell
at one point it was romantic and then it
seemed to shift into something
professional and financial
guillen was madly in love with him
everybody said at the time and that was
very unfortunate people told me because
he was not madly in love
with her he used her she was somebody
who introduced him to all the powerful
people she knew the powerful people
she'd grown up with as the daughter of
robert maxwell
in 2008 jeffrey epstein pleaded guilty
to soliciting and procuring a minor for
prostitution he struck a controversial
deal with prosecutors who spent 18
months in prison
he served just 30 and was allowed to
leave each day
in 2019 new sex trafficking charges were
brought against jeffrey epstein and he
was denied bail
but before he was brought to trial he
died in jail in an apparent suicide
some worried that the hopes of
uncovering the truth about jeffrey
epstein died when he did this trial is
now perhaps the best chance of unlocking
some of the mysteries surrounding him
the crimes are alleged to have taken
place in london where gillette maxwell
had a house
at mr epstein's mansion in palm beach
florida
at his sprawling ranch in new mexico
and here at his vast townhouse in
manhattan gelane maxwell is facing six
counts of sex trafficking between 1994
and 2004 against four alleged victims
prosecutors say the youngest was 14
years old
essentially she stands accused of
grooming young women gaining their trust
buying them gifts normalizing sexual
conversations also jeffrey epstein could
abuse them
gillane maxwell has consistently denied
the charges and pleaded not guilty
after epstein's death there was a search
for his friend and former girlfriend who
police eventually tracked down and
arrested on a remote estate in new
hampshire called tucked away
she has been in jail ever since
repeatedly refused bail and put on
suicide watch her brother ian maxwell
has taken issue with the way she's been
treated she's lost weight she's not
losing her hair
we know that she's suffered some kind of
physical abuse because she had a black
eye do you believe that your sister has
been beaten by prison guards i think she
has suffered some
occasional physical abuse at the hands
of her guards yes
[Music]
twelve jurors will decide gilley
maxwell's fate in a trial expected to
last at least six weeks
it has yet to be revealed exactly what
evidence prosecutors will present here
at court and who is cooperating with
them but pre-trial hearings suggest they
will call an expert witness on grooming
and show the jury a contact book it is
also possible they have footage from the
extensive cctv systems that jeffrey
epstein had installed in his homes
each side will have a very different
strategy the challenge for prosecutors
is to make sure that these witnesses are
believable right to present their
testimony in a way that plugs the memory
gaps because there's been such long
periods of time here that the defense
will argue they've made up their minds
via other means prosecution must fight
that
we don't know if gilay maxwell will
testify
but a defense team probably don't know
either
that decision is often made late on
but has its dangers
generally speaking most criminal
defendants don't testify there's an
inherent risk in testimony because you
open yourself up to extensive
cross-examination it's a
cross-examination as to prior criminal
conduct prior bad acts prior immoral
conduct possibly so that decision has
not been made yet but it's unlikely just
statistically speaking
if convicted guillaine maxwell faces
decades in jail and she may not be the
last epstein associate to go on trial
[Music]
you